I had never heard of this company that
you showed me Heritage Auctions yeah I
think that auctions particularly
marketplaces
I would love someone to criticize this
because I want to hear the downsides I
think that they are potentially one of
the top like two or three business
models auctions or more Oxford's and
marketplaces marketplaces for sure yeah
but auction style marketplaces I think
they were they're one of the bests yeah
you've seen a bunch of them yeah I think
you babying this sort of classic yeah
and I think eBay sucks by the way
there's some one's totally gonna crush
them I mean they're gonna be dead not
dead but somebody told me this is half
half information somebody told me eBay
has had like a revival and they don't do
the auction stuff as much anymore
they're all like it's basically Amazon
is yeah I can hate it but I hate it but
if somebody said that their numbers have
turned around I don't know if that's
true well they're a behemoth they're not
going anywhere anytime soon I mean
they're like Google like you're like oh
well they're sucking like okay I mean
they're gonna last for another 50 years
at least yeah so anyway I love auctions
I like I'll and I love niche auctions
and heritage which you pointed out they
do that you got the you got that pulled
up Henry and you could pull it up on
your phone so they did 800 million
dollars in sales so it's not on the
screen so let's look at the top
categories you have it on your phone
yeah so coins I think was their top
right yeah so they do I think 300
million dollars in currency right okay
but look at some of the more interesting
ones movie posters ten million ten
million dollars in sales what was comics
comics is on there yeah I just pull it
up
what's it say for comics Henry comics 50
sports 60 million more collectibles
basically mm-hmm luxury real estate 19
million wine 10 million crazy right tons
crazy and here's what I like about it
this is a big idea we talk a lot in fact
I have a pet peeve we talk a lot about
these like small little business
arbitrage is hacks little businesses
this would be a big big company if you
could get this
right and so what so I love I love
marketplaces and I love auctions I love
auctions because there's a time
component to it yeah and that urgency
makes you buy more and what I think is
even better and so for heritage auctions
I think roughly half of their sales of a
$10,000,000 sales are online and the
other half are in person you want to
know another in-person auction that's
doing wonderfully Jackson have you heard
of barrett-jackson what is the
barrett-jackson is based in Arizona
bootstrap done by one guy is that his
name Barrett
maybe Burt Barrett is dead Jackson is
alive okay or it could be the other way
around one of them is dead but what they
do is they actually have a they put this
on TV all the time I watch it all the
time what they do is sell cars to
classic cars right not all classic cars
but just like rare or like interesting
cars you can buy like a $10,000 car
there but so they'll have a car on and
they'll say like this Ferrari there was
only 500 of them this it sells for
$200,000 and they show it and you're
like how awesome that sale just happened
in three minutes that was great and so
they do I believe 68 shows a year and
they make hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue yeah it's a huge
business and I love that and so another
one is bring a trailer they do cars as
well and the guy who started bring a
trailer also started mailbox Gentry
Underwood so he's like a but she's sold
to Dropbox and so I like these auction
places and first of all I like niche
auctions so I like watches anything
that's niche but but what do you what is
another and I have one an idea idea
what's a current marketplace that's very
illiquid and hard to sell and you wish I
could go away faster mm-hm
houses is one luxury house they put on
here because takes a while to sell a
house in general and so open doors
trying to make that instant as a market
as a real estate company but not as much
as an auction mmm I have a friend who
did this with sneakers he had low doing
that now I think it's working well did
it as a 90 minute auction so he would
say the sneaker goes live it's 90
minutes and we're gonna get you your
guaranteed price
or we they basically offer the seller
they're like we will buy it at this
price if the auction doesn't go higher
so if you agree to that you start the
process and it's 90 minutes what else I
don't know what else yeah small
businesses
okay just flip my business and this is a
maybe would just fall flat this is one
of those it could be amazing or it would
just be horribly idea but if I were
quiet like brokerage who sponsors this
or if I were another brokerage I would
100% have an event and try to gather a
thousand people and we're gonna auction
off these businesses my idea from
yesterday the first dibs where you're
auctioning future the future first a
future first whatever you're gonna
create I think that would work really
well with this as well but business is
the hard part is you have there's so
many hard parts about it there's a lot
of hard but one is just the diligence
right so like when I buy the the movie
poster or whatever if it has sort of the
certification and the the person selling
it sort of says this is authentic I
don't need to look too much more into it
whereas with a business you really have
to sort of understand all these
different components I think that's hard
I agree it's hard but I think it's
interesting right because like if
someone just like if I knew Shopify apps
or something and there's this gathering
and they're just auctioning off a [__]
ton of them and it's kind of like a
storage war or it's like which you know
what you get but let's just find out
like it could be fun to gamble tens of
thousands of dollars yeah just storage
units that would be interesting like a
mystery box basically that you're buying
oh [__] yeah that would be really that
would be really fun and and interesting
is it have to be cheap enough that's
interesting John it's someone doing
store storage unit like blind auctions
yeah yeah surely they have to be right I
don't know but you can tell you some of
these ideas together right so like what
HQ showed where they did basically they
took a traditional TV show and turn it
into a live streaming mobile app where
the game shows on on your phone this is
the future of TV like you can do a QVC
or I don't know what show you talked
about you watch the auctions on but like
you can that repair jacket but there's
another one called but turn these into
mobile live streamed shows and you can
essentially sell these all through
through you know you could take so one
way to look at this Roadshow that's what
I was thinking about right so one way to
look at this is you you start selling
some item that's not currently sold on
the auction place
might be hard because a lot of time has
passed and sort of like you know the law
of supply demand has pulled things that
want to be sold this way into the market
but maybe you could find a new niche or
you just take the existing platforms and
you make them smaller more lightweight
and mobile focused you just win that way
and so like I don't know top hat er yeah
what an incredible company
it's wish so it's a mobile app where you
see a bunch of really cheap stuff from
China random stuff it can be like a back
brace and a ring and a you know whatever
a poster - ooh
dollar store crap dollars for well it's
like the it's like the wish crap which
is like random electronics and
memorabilia items yeah laser pointers
and class rings and like you know
whatever but what they do is if it which
is interesting is it's a fish the items
start so you open up the app and you see
all these things in it like you've never
seen your adrenalin spike like this in a
mobile app before all the prices are
starting it like what are 50 dollars and
they just start dropping and then
somebody just hits buy and then they buy
it and so you kind of want to wait to
get it lower but you don't want to wait
too long if somebody else is gonna buy
it so top Hatters a start-up here in San
Francisco and they do hundreds of
millions of dollars for having a very
good is a very interesting business I
don't know how profitable it is how
sticky it is blah blah blah but when you
go into the app it's like a it's like
being in like this high-stakes Chinese
market does dollar auction like those
penny auctions things it's a little bit
all like a little bit like that but they
but you don't have to buy credits and
stuff like that it's more like wish but
instead of that what they tap into is
instead of browsing and picking they
pick they like inject into your FOMO
you know part of your brain and so
you're like okay this item do I want it
do I want it for 6 bucks 5 bucks 4 bucks
3 I'll take it and you end up buying a
whole bunch of [__] and it's just a
bunch of moms who are bored at home that
are just shopping on this thing and they
feel like hey we're getting tons of
value but like this is stuff you didn't
even know you wanted you don't even want
this is [__] it's just [__] and as I'm
gonna download it and buy some stuff I'm
like [__] all the time
how powders cool
[Music]